ضاقت فسحه الامل بالنسبه لان الى حدود هذه
الغرفه الصغيره داخل مركز للنازحين في
اكياس
قساوه الحرب باديه في عيون اطفالها وفي
الاشواك التي زينت رسم صغيرتها صوفيا
الاحتلال والخوف من حالات الاغتصاب التي
سمعنا عنها
وتركت ابني بالثمانيه عشر عاما في
بريديانس استلم زوجي دعوه للانضمام
للتجنيد منذ يومين لا ينبغي ان يذهب الى
الحرب انه ابو لسته اطفال هو المعيد
الوحيد لنا قصه ان تشبه قصص نساء كثيرات
هنا في اوكرانيا الاف منهن فقدنا ازواجهن
او ابنائهم واخريات يعشنا الخوف على من
تبقى لهن من احب لكنهن قررنا المواجهه كل
واحده على طريقتها
في احدى محطات المترو تنتظرونيه مع فريق
طبي وصول الركاب لاعطائهم دروسا في
الاسعافات الاوليه
اسعافات تقول انها بات الضروريه في زمن
الحرب
في طبيب ومع بدايه الحرب ذهب متطوعا للعمل
مسعفا على الخطوط الاماميه وانضم حاليا
للجيش اصبح عامل هناك
بصرف النظر عن القصف يجب علي انجاز المهمه
وتقديم العون الاصابات للاسف اصبحت خطيره
وداميه وهذا امر مريع
كينيا شابه اوكرانيه اخرى تقدم معظم وقتها
في هذا المكان منذ بدايه الحرب هنا تجد
المجندات ما يحتاج له في جبهه القتال
انا صحفيه وكان لدي مشروع قبل الحرب لكن
حاليا اساعده فيتامين احتياجات المراه
العسكريه فهمت بعد انضمام اخت زوجي للجيش
ان هناك احتياجات للمراه لا تتوفر في
الجبهه الاوازم الصحيه والدروع والاوزان
الخفيفه والثياب والاحذيه العسكريه
بالمقاسات المناسبه غيرت الحرب فينا كل
شيء لكنه تغير نحو الافضل
نحو الافضل هذا امل الاوكرانيين وقد شارفت
الحرب الروسيه على بلادهم ان تدخل عامها
الثاني امل لا يقتصر على النساء وحسب بل
يجمع الملايين ممن رمد بهم الحرب على سكه
مستقبل مجهول كاترين حنا الجزيره كيف